[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey come on
[Music]
[Music]
crap
hey brother we found you loose
now get rid of her
[Music]
um
[Applause]
do you think it's another puzzle or
whatever it is you better figure it out
for us i'm trying to buy some time
hey can i get you a drink
it definitely is machine and sonic but
it is on the house
yes
okay whoa whoa whoa let me go pina
colada
[Music]
okay i got it i got it
six on the beach
let's go
it's pretty cool
he's uh huh
of a kind solid gold alter cruise
effects and crafted in barcelona in the
early 16th centuries yes yeah it's
pretty cool
you are a collector my table i don't
dabble this cross has a very tragic
history
80 men died trying to hold on to it so
much blood so needlessly spilled
ladies and gentlemen if i could have
your attention please
be commencing very soon
[Music]
now
twice
[Music]
you're doing great hang in there
oh my god
hey trent addison wanted to take that to
the vault pronto
thanks
sully where are you going there's only
one rule in this game ken don't get
caught
oh my god
there has to be another keyhole up there
somewhere that opened this door i'm like
literally in a papa john's right now
i found it excuse me guys
hand it over victor give me the cross
sully hurry
shut up i'm working on it i'll shut up
when you get the hell out of here
[Music]
hey kid a little young for a bartender
aren't you a little old for prom aren't
you
[Music]
everything in here why the map it's the
biggest treasure that's never been found
five billion easy
but it's just a story i beg to differ
[Music]
500 years ago
my family found the world's biggest
fortune
then was betrayed
people have been searching for it all in
vain
both the attorney keys clockwise at the
same time
thanks a lot you almost got me killed
clockwise sully oh it was 50 50 so i
made a guess clearly
but the voyage was not just about gold
or something much more valuable this
gross has a very tragic history so much
blood
[Music]
i'm pretty sure he's just threatening to
kill me
don't get caught
you were just gonna leave me back there
somebody had to get the cross
[Music]
[Applause]
your brother believed that there was a
final piece
well you know my brother said
you have no idea who you partnered with
what else aren't you telling me
the victor
spoils
how are they gonna get them out of here
wow
[Music]
hey put them down boys
what is that thing on your face yeah
puberty's right around the corner kids
you can grow your own
exclusively in movie theaters
i think the thing i loved most about the
game uncharted was the adventure and
incredible action and humor that was a
little more your size here cute and to
have the opportunity to bring it to life
was a lot of fun so when do we start
here pretend you're here
hello hello i can hear him sitting right
next to you when you're making a
spider-man movie the sky is the limit
spider-man can essentially do anything
whereas in this film nathan drake at the
end of the day is human so designing
these action sequences around that was
really exciting
[Music]
you're doing great i trained very much
for agility
but when i stood next to mark i realized
how big he was and i was like man i
really need to put on some timber here
because i'm gonna look like his nephew
we better get small or in your case
smaller so i trained my ass off you're
only like one inch taller than me it's a
little more than that kid i'm very proud
of what we've achieved it's an action
adventure movie it's about being daring
and taking risks come on it's a film
that really keeps you on your toes hey
you still with me
barely
[Music]
you